[Musique]
hier soir tpm terreau sauver la légende
du rap français b2oba pendant près d'une
heure le duc de boulogne se prêtait à
notre séquence booba face à l'actuelle
séquence ou booba avait la possibilité
de zapper ou pas un sujet grâce à son
buzzer si dans l'ensemble il a répondu à
tous les sujets sans concession il
semblerait qu'un débat face à jean
messia sur la dangerosité du rap chez
les jeunes ne l'est pas vraiment emballé
pour l'ehpad est ce que tu avais peur
le front national s'est muni de son
buzzer que le rappeur a littéralement
next et l'homme politique qui a été
contraint de quitter le plateau
telle était la règle et non sur les
femmes là entre la haine contre les
homosexuels sa détestation séquence qui
a fait beaucoup rire sur les réseaux
mais qui n'a pas plu à notre jean
messier a complètement furent at je
reste alors vous bas refusent de
débattre avec jean missia êtes vous
d'accord avec booba alors merci jean
messia d'être là c'est vrai que hier
vous êtes parti il paraît que vous étiez
très triste de partir comme ça triste
non mais c'est toujours un peu frustrant
d'être invité à débattre avec quelqu'un
qui ne veut pas débattre
non mais il avait un an mais il n'a pas
voulu ne pas débattre c'était c'était la
règle du jeu puisque on le dit un buzzer
voilà au bout d'un moment et c'est vrai
que j'avais dit à la production est
jonnie de prévenir les intervenants de
leur dire qu'ils peuvent peut-être resté
35 ans mais c'était très c'était très
méprisant vis-à-vis de moi et vis-à-vis
des autres qui ont subi le même sort
je crois que la france est un pays
démocratique donc le désamour n'est pas
un crime
alors je comprends que mes là là là là
le jeu comprend que booba n'a pas
suffisamment de mots de vocabulaire pour
les 9 10 minutes les brillants mais là
en l'occurrence il s'agissait de porter
la contradiction non mais attendez gens
que j'étais un principe d'une règle à
respecter une scénarisation et dans ce
cas là c'est aussi votre faute parce que
moi j'accepte n'aurait pas si j'étais
animateur j'accepterai pas que quelqu'un
vienne dans mon émission moi c'est moi
qui fixe les règles mission je dicte et
les conditions du débat mais non mais en
plus le débat les ongles en mai via les
terminaux mais le débat est inégal parce
que faire un débat où l'un des
débatteurs mais non ici l'argentine
instrument lui permettant pas c'est
comme si vous m'aviez tiens rien donné
c'est la mécanique du jeu
si vous m'aviez un ring d'accord pour
macbook battre avec quelqu'un et vous
lui donnez un 357 magnum celui d'inviter
du chocolat mais non mais toute façon je
crois que vous avez rien compris à la
mécanique puisqu'il ya des gens qui sont
sortis juste avant vous donc c'est des
jeunes l'objectif maintenant est
d'inviter des lampes pour qui fait
rigoler c'était l'objectif c'est un
format où ils pouvaient accepter lui
navigué comme leurs invités
je voulais linverse al'inverse vous
arrivez sur un vieux débat qui date de
2016 sur l'homophobie
vous arrivez sur une recherche google
est la première chose que vous pointez
seller de trucs qui ont fait par
aiguille et en 2016 et où il a bien
expliqué d'ailleurs sur ce plateau en
2016 que c'était métaphore donc
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que le mec il
il ay dialoguer avec vous dans ces
moments là maintenant long je suis pas
pour
parce qu'effectivement pour combattre
l'ignorance il faut dialoguer dans leur
moi je n'ai pas vu le dialogué ces
questions alors si moi j'avais été
invité et que j'avais traité booba de
cette façon là tous les honorables
correspondants est si présente aura
traité d'un bonnet la mer et je vous
l'avais pas en cause les gens saison
s'est produit à bord elle et personne
n'a rien dit et ça lui est incroyable si
je vous avais proposé un buzzer j'aurais
compris tout à fait guillaume déjà on va
pas se mentir une star durant de booba
qui vient sur un plateau et qui n'a
aucune exigence sur les invités ça
n'existe pas lui on lui a dit voilà il y
aura une sorcière il y aura jean messia
il y aura un membre du red hill à rien
est déjà sur le papier
en vrai il ya plein de stars turdine
wells alors j'ai pas envie de ressasser
ça il a accepté d'entamer remettez
jamais le débat avec vous deuxièmement
il acceptait deuxièmement il y avait une
mécanique c'était la mécanique de buzzer
juste avant il a besoin une sorcière qui
restait trente secondes ça n'a choqué
personne vous ça doit choquer tout le
monde on sait pas pourquoi
karine en visionnement pardon vous avez
accueilli booba qui est quand même une
grande star que vous vouliez ou non
mercialys en défense allemande ikb ainsi
c'est une énorme star est en classe 3 et
venir étant des biens en droit de le
dire sur un plateau pour dire qu'on ait
un désaccord avec vous
chose la patrie de ramener le garrido le
venezuela on est d'accord mais
accueillir à quand des martyrs ont dit
en sous-entendant que sa musique c'est
de la merde parce que j'ai dit que j'ai
pape a ensuite fait pas regarder écouter
connaissez-vous bah oui oui mais bien
humainement je sais pas mais j'aime pas
ça soit honnête
moi je n'aime pas badie le mais je te
connais pas et humainement donc je peux
pas t'aider je peux pas dire si je
t'aime ou pas ce genre c'est normal
qu'on arrive comme ça moi vous arriver
sur nos côtes et vous dites je sais pas
toi mais j'aime pas tes émissions là
mais le magueresse braquage il devrait
pas les martyrs très franchement
monsieur jouez pas les martyrs de vingré
vous traitement particulier je vous
laisse parler arrivé qu un ego démesuré
pour faire du buzz elle fracassée et ben
il vous a viré et moi je lui dis il a
bien fait de vous virer ou alors les
gens les gens les gens qui qui qui vote
extrême droite bien entendu il faut leur
parler il faut convaincre mais vous là
vous êtes arrivé je vois les épaules et
chacun vote pour qu'ils veulent c'est
exactement ce que dit on n'est pas des
donneurs de leçons et ses juges perd sa
juste quand j'ai dit pas oui aux gens
qui votent extrêmement qu'il faut leur
parler mais avoue il a bien fait vous
virer celle que vous étiez arrivé
spécifiquement pour faire une séquence
avec lui lui taper dessus en temps comme
vous n'avez même pas dit je vous aime en
tant qu'homme je ne sais pas si je vous
ai menti navire est que le buzzer il a
bien fait vous vous étiez vous étiez
journaliste je crois oui je sais vous
pourrez vous poursuivez la pelure le
pluralisme que vous avez pratiqué dans
la presse vous poursuivez ici mais
d'accord mais hier j'ai particulièrement
peu apprécié votre intervention parce
que normalement c'est un débat c'est pas
moi qui ai demandé à venir est celui qui
avait à l'ego démesuré c'était
certainement pas moi c'était le c'était
le pingouin en survêtement j'avais en
face de moi demain 6 rue et 6 6 3 lire
ce que j'ai le droit de dire ce que je
veux et si ça vous plaît pas c'est
pareil
moubarak ans et ça c'est pas parce que
ce mec pèse 185 millions d'euros qu'il
faut ça plate rs carapater devant lui
c'est à vos valeurs c'est une vraie
chance est l invité dans l'émission mais
fait très peu d'émissions ou le lieu
dont lui expliquer les règles on a dit
voilà il ya une règle et un buzzer si tu
n'as plus envie de débattre tu peux buzz
est moindre mais moi ma vie puisse alors
à l'âge et à l'est mais c'est plus moi
le responsable pelouse il faut que
j'étais l'espagne les faut que vos
téléspectateurs c'est moi qui ai fixé la
règle que moi j'ai été appelé par vos
équipes pour venir débattre alors vous
allez vous me dites qu'il a accepté le
principe du débat
mais cette éventuelle mais il accepte il
a accepté que je vienne 45 secondes pour
me dire j'ai pas envie de débattre à
midi du 4 4 il est en plus sous les
applaudissements des grands démocrates
que ici présents alors laquelle raquel
ah bah oui mais c'est normal
le coltine en permanence c'est normal
c'est votre vie sur les démissions de
cyril hanouna qui est quand même pas moi
moi vous avez général beaucoup beaucoup
de temps d'antenne tout ça donc
parce que je suis au projet il n'y a pas
le dette parce que moi je suis quelqu'un
de plutôt comment dire ouverts à la
discussion j'aime bien débattre même
avec des gens avec qui je suis
radicalement opposé mais j'explique
principe du jeu c'est pas broyer déjà
mais en plus je ça ne m'étonne pas
qu'ils aient des gens qui avaient pu
débattre avec vous vu le niveau auquel
vous placez en général vos arguments par
exemple à tout à l'heure vous avez dit
que ma patrie c'était le venezuela pour
l'état c'est nul comme argument mais
vous fait pire puisque vous avez même
attaqué mes parents vous avez dit que
mes parents qui ont été convaincants
subi la prison politiquement ils ont été
combinés dont était maudit occasions
étaient dans les violences
insurrectionnelles et devrait causer un
coup d'état et cds tête c'est une auge
et c'est vrai il vous avez non ce n'est
pas vrai un autre débat mais je crois
que ce soir je vous ai pas traité de
merde sur twitter d'accord vous parlez
des arguments qui sont mis la barre
voilà je crois que vous avez battu des
roms avec volant c'est qu'en fait c'est
que ça sert à rien de débattre avec bien
sûr votre avis votre idéologie nommé
parce que vous avez aucun argument
m'oppose au c'est ça le problème
j'aimerais si on peut parler de
l'histoire du chili
madame j'ai fait j'ai fait beaucoup de
noirs ou là dessus a dit à jacques tati
alors moi sincèrement je pense que le
problème ce n'est pas l'opinion que vous
apportez mais bien la manière dont vous
l'exprimez des veaux première phrase
quand vous êtes arrivé sur plateau tout
le monde savait déjà ce que vous allez
dire c'est vraiment des phrases mais
infondée suite il alors vous êtes envie
de m'en débarrasser
le problème c'est que toute la fin je
suis pas content de la manière dont vous
exprimez vos opinions sont un finish est
incroyable a cliché que les jeunes en
ont marre d'entendre que booba en tant
que pionnier du rap en à main en a marre
d'entendre au c est le cliché mais de
quoi vous parlez tous les clichés dont
douze au retour des convictions avait
déjà prédit que vous allez dire que le
râle mais je n'avais pas indiqué portent
effectivement des convictions mais qui
sont ni moins honorable ni moins
respectables que les opinions et les et
les conditions soyez juste honnête avec
quelque chose hier vous ne cherchez pas
le débat avec lui c'est la première que
vous êtes arrivé sur le plateau vous
l'avait attaquée alors dire à quelqu'un
qui a combattu ça il ya 16 ans et qui a
expliqué aussi il ya pardon il ya quatre
ans et qui explique aussi pourquoi parce
que en réalité vous connaissez pas booba
vous avez jamais écouté de musique j'ai
écouté mon grand souci
parce que figurez vous quand vous
regardez ce que les médias il y à ce qui
se passe sur le plateau et il y à
l'opinion des milieux sûr c'est qu'ils
regardent et je peux vous dire que ça
n'a pas fait honneur à booba la manière
dont il s'est comporté un petit bijou
ici les gens ici il a été blessé moi
finir fils et lycées il a été ici il a
été applaudi mais il a été désigné sur
les jours ci aux gens vous avez vous
auriez commencé comme ça vous aurait dit
oui je vois que j'ai promis que mes
enfants adorent
déjà je n'aurais pas été terrible je
vais juste vous dire un truc
parmi les messages émis les centaines de
milliers de messages que j'ai reçus hier
j'ai reçu des messages y compris des
deux de gens du maghreb d'afrique etc
qui me disent moi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce que vous dites mais je
trouve que la manière dont doit vous a
traité hier était scandaleuse mais ils
sont pas d'accord avec nous beaucoup de
gens qui malgrès afin aussi de ce qu'il
a été ces 12 selon les deux beaucoup de
gens du maghreb disent que quand on
invite le mot invitation si vous voulez
là il a fait qui fait que j'ai un amis
arabes fait part à ses jeunes amis et
moi on était allé des gens du maghreb
mais arrêtez aurait-il du mans les gens
du maghreb ou dans ce projet les
magasins comme en france on est là pour
la plupart étaient très heureux que
booba vous et cas parce que non non non
enfin jours maintenant les jeunes gens
n'étaient pas résisté aux heureux sont
ceux qui sont à quel âge à limours eux
se sont se sont ce sont ceux qui n'ont
qu elles qui ont un concept un peu
fumeux de la démocratie comme celle-là
ça c'est la première chose j'en suis là
des gens c'est de l'autre côté qui ont
dit que vous aviez été un peu dur avec
booba dès le début alors mais nous reste
sonné mais en quoi est ce que c'est dur
de dire qu'on n'aime pas un style
musical
non mais vous êtes tous entrain de dire
depuis une demi heure que vous n'aimez
pas viser mes idées vous alors vous avez
le droit de garder moi j'ai pas le droit
d'écouter votre année c'est incroyable
mais ces gens il ya des gens qui ont le
droit de gérer non genre jusque là ça
puisque vous l'avez rêvé je voulais
c'est trop de secondes dit voilà c'est
vous qu'elle est calé finir le débat
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire moi ce
que j'ai à dire c'est que si on m'avait
laissé continuer j'aurais eu un débat de
fond avec lui et je lui ai d'ailleurs je
l'aurais je leur ai félicité pour son
évolution musicale parce que ce qui ce
cil ce qu'il chantait il y a une dizaine
d'années c'est parce qu'il chante
aujourd'hui passant est génial mais le
problème c'est qu'au bout de quarante
secondes c'était donc à le débat on ôte
des buts qu'on le continue on le termine
du spectateur
moi j'écoute et du rap quand j'étais
jeune je sais pas si vous connaissez un
rapport qui s'appelle bennabi gênait pas
gêné par endroits c'est une vision que
vous l'avez deviné il disait c'est le
rap français s'en sortit à vous êtes
fous et le gars est né à molenbeek vous
imaginez l'évolution depuis les années
1990 jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec des
rappeurs comme médine et ses amis l'ont
applaudi toute la racaille anti-france
d'ars qui est applaudi ban détruisent
c'est l'association vous êtes s'était
muni vie vous bénéficierez faire
pardonner dr je vous offre l'intégrale
de bénéfices et pour moi c'est ça